una inundación táctica suena
contradictorio pero eso es exactamente
lo que sucedió aquí a 60 kilómetros al
norte de la capital el segundo día de la
guerra el ejército ucraniano amenazado
con abrir la presa de irving para
inundar el campo y detener los tanques
rusos la desventaja el agua lleno del
pueblo de de madrid
ciudad el agua llegó a este nivel todo
se inundó un segundo tono donde estoy
en comparación con lo que está pasando
en otras partes de ucrania
no estamos sufriendo así que no estoy
bien a eso me acordé de más de manera
coreo decor
iván no es el único que apoya a las
inundaciones pero las reparaciones
llevarán tiempo solo tienen esta bomba
para todo el pueblo
tenemos un nuevo protocolo
vignoli de la ciudad de corrientes
o sea
podemos cine mal
la presa en sí fue escenario de feroces
combates y ahora está inoperable antes
de la batalla este empleado ayudó a
abrir la cerradura e inundó del pueblo
ya no hay problema
creo que fue una buena idea hacerlo
porque de lo contrario los tanques rusos
habrían podido pasar fácilmente pero en
cambio los tanques se atascaron y kiev
estaba a salvo
no sólo fue la represa el ejército
ucraniano
deliberadamente destruyó al menos 300 de
sus puentes para ralentizar el avance
ruso